let me ask you about the chauvin trial
so you you wrote a lot about it i was
following your writing during the
chauvin trial and
the media was only giving us one side of
the story it was it was remarkable when
i'd go to nbc and they'd be talking
about what the state prosecutor the
prosecutor's witness said this this and
this and they were all really great for
the prosecutor right and then on cross
when the defense actually challenged
these ideas and did great did great they
would they would say nothing so sure
enough you mentioned uh earlier that a
lot of people begin to expect a
conviction like or at least an
indictment with with darren wilson in
ferguson people were shocked when this
guy was not charged with anything it's
because the media wasn't giving him the
truth however over a long enough period
of time with propaganda and manipulation
and riots this time not only did they
get their indictment they got a
conviction on all charges
so not only is the media giving a false
view of things but now it seems to be
working
right so by the way a little inside
baseball that whole darren wilson case
with michael brown
the reason he didn't get indicted was
the prosecutor there
made the decision to show the grand jury
both sides of the argument the facts in
favor of guilt misconduct by the officer
and the facts that mitigate that made it
look appear to be a justifiable use of
force and he let the grand jury make the
decision he had no obligation to do that
he could have only offered the half of
the story that would have gotten the
officer indicted but he offered both
sides grand jury looked at it said nope
looks like a justified use of force to
us you know what happened to our
prosecutor next election he had a soros
backed candidate who defeated him as
prosecutor and that guy ran in part the
competitor uh ran apart on immediately
reopening the michael brown case so he
did is that happening yeah he reopened
it looked at it for three weeks close it
again immediately because there's simply
no evidence consistent with the officer
having done anything wrong but he won
the election so he's now in that seat he
won political power through this uh
propagandistic narrative i don't know
how you solve that problem man
well people need to people need to know
who their prosecutor is i bet nobody at
this table knows who the local
prosecutor is here because normal people
don't know right you need to know you
need to care these are enormously
powerful positions and they're cheap to
buy most prosecutorial races involve a
few thousand dollars so someone's
willing to come in and drop fifty
thousand dollars in a process he just
bought that seat well so so there has
been a wave of progressive or leftist
da's we just had a story and this one's
going to get us in trouble on youtube
but the uh what's what's the guy's name
chesa bowden you know this guy in san
francisco
he's a progressive prosecutor and he had
a domestic abuser arrested twice and he
cut him loose twice saying oh but the
wife won't
you know won't uh file charges against
him right even though in california
domestic violence is a charge from the
state this it's it's you're victimizing
the state in this case and i do that
because of course the victim who's being
beaten by you isn't going to speak out
well after get released twice
he went back home and he murdered a
seven-year-old baby
so this is what happens when you get i
don't want to draw a direct one-to-one
correlation between him being this like
new woke d.a
and releasing this guy but it is
consistent with what we've seen from
these leftist prosecutors who are like
i'm gonna let this guy go
well you don't get less crime by letting
all the bad guys you've arrested
immediately out of prison
this is the same prosecutor who told his
assistant das
don't argue three strikes under florida
law for any of these people that that
are being brought into court pretend
three strikes doesn't exist now
reasonable people can agree or disagree
about whether they think three strikes
is good public policy or not but here
the prosecutors under him actually went
to court to fight his order and maybe
they don't agree with three strikes
themselves but it would be unlawful
under state law for them to do he was
telling his prosecutors to act
unlawfully in arguing their cases in
court and they weren't willing to accept
that legal liability well who was the
prosecutor in the uh derrick chauvin
trial
well they had a whole password i'm sorry
who uh who was the one who basically
initiated the charges
i don't know who would have initiated it
they had they had at least four
prosecutors in court themselves oh keith
ellison the state attorney general right
um well what happened in that case was
the local prosecutor didn't want
anything to do with the case basically
and handed it off to the state so the
state would take responsibility which
keith ellison was happy to do yeah
and of course he then brought in a whole
panel of prosecutors only two of whom
were actual state prosecutors
of the 10 or 12 attorneys admitted to
prosecute that case only two were state
prosecutors all the others were private
attorneys from from very high-end law
firms who volunteered to work for free
to prosecute their how is that legal how
is that allowed they're he's permitted
to bring in anybody he wants that the
court will accept as
an attorney for that case and the
court's generally willing to accept and
these they're all excellent attorneys
they're all very very good attorneys but
it's it was a gross mismatch between
these 10 or 12 prosecutors uh working on
the state side and one
frankly run-of-the-mill defense attorney
perfectly nice guy perfectly capable
attorney but nothing special working for
the defense is there anything in modern
history that would reflect like is
similar to what we saw with shoving
meaning the state brings in prestigious
prosecutors
they that the city settles with the
floyd family during the during the trial
have you ever seen anything no i've not
and it's extremely unusual to especially
during jury selection there's no point
then to rush to a settlement you may as
well wait and see if criminal liability
has been found uh do a settlement after
the fact if they'd settled very quickly
after the event i wouldn't have been
surprised but to wait as long as they
did to jury selection and then suddenly
rush to settlement knowing the biasing
effect and maybe that's why it was done
knowing the biasing effect that it would
have
and i've never seen the case in which
the large majority of the quote-unquote
prosecutors on the case were actually
private attorneys who were brought in as
a kind of hit team that seems crazy to
me but you know it seems crazy to me
after that is who in their right mind
would stay in minnesota i mean the state
i mean keith ellison's the ag right so
this is statewide that means if you're a
cop anywhere in minnesota right and you
do anything to save someone else or
protect yourself you're going to prison
and this is increasingly common this is
a pattern now where people might think
hey i don't live in the city it's safe
where i live i live out in the country
it's a nice safe community i know who my
prosecutor is i see him at the grocery
store every once in a while he's a nice
guy i'm sure he wouldn't prosecute me
but what often happens is a local
prosecutor gets removed from the
decision-making process and it gets
handed off to a chosen prosecutor from a
different district that happened in the
george zimmerman trial the local
prosecutor
to him it was so clearly self-defense he
he quit his job rather than bring
charges against george zimmerman and
they just brought in deborah nelson from
a different part of florida to be the
prosecutor in that case or you see the
case handed off to a state-level
prosecutor uh like with keith ellison in
the chauvin trial or with the ahmad
arbury case in in georgia you have a
prosecutor local prosecutor looks at it
i don't want to bring charges here
second prosecutor i don't want to bring
charges third prosecutor
i don't want anything to do with it and
they hand it off to a prosecutor from
another part of the state why why are
they handing it off because it's a
political hot potato everybody knows
what benjamin crump is going to turn the
case into they don't want any part of it
maybe they should grow some spines
or maybe they they're they feel the
political pressure they're going to face
is simply going to be overwhelming for
someone who spent fifteen hundred
dollars to become a local prosecutor
fifteen hundred dollars it's amazing
it's it's kind of scary that it's that
cheap to buy one of these one of these
positions
yeah you make a good point with the
michael brown thing where the prosecutor
got he ousted and they brought his job
lost his job so it seems like even if
they do gross bond and say get away from
me they'll just lose their job and
they'll bring in somebody else that's
what happens man propaganda is is is
taking over and i gotta say it's making
me pretty pessimistic you know i try to
be optimistic a little bit sometimes i'm
i am fairly pessimistic which is a
problem but uh you know we've had some
we've had some uh you know james
carville comes out says whoa this is a
problem there there are some signs that
maybe we're starting to see people
realize the problem of the these
narratives
but then i hear this stuff and it's been
ongoing for like a decade and the
chauvin trial was the worst of the worst
where
i mean when i i think it was the
the lapd use of force expert i think it
was
was it was it him who said sergeant
steiger for the for the state was he the
guy who said that chauvin was entitled
to use a taser and chose not to yeah he
absolutely was because of course taser
is non-deadly force so how do you
convince a jury that chauvin was
intending to assault or injure floyd
when he de-escalated he used a lesser
force option and even called ems
because that wasn't really the question
that the jury was being asked to answer
the question was not how do we decide
this case on the legal merits the
question was do we want to convict this
guy and all go home and live a quiet
life or do we want to acquit on any one
of these charges and be burned alive in
our homes the woman one of the one of
the jurors she didn't know she was an
alternate and i'm sure you saw this said
i didn't want to go through the riots
and the destruction again and i was
worried someone would come to my house
and retaliate right and you can hardly
blame her because the threat of violence
is real there's a reason they had
national guardsmen outside the
courthouse there was barbed wire the
jurors were escorted to the courtroom by
state police with machine guns this is
not because the the threat of violence
is famous that machine guns like you
mean it well you know your guns yeah
the state police are would be armed with
mp5s or something equivalent so the
actual select fire right yeah sure
they're not
they're not law enforcement doesn't
doesn't buy semi automatically right
right there's no restriction on them
having full auto so great they're
allowed to have weapons of war i suppose
that's you know sure
it's it's okay and the jurors of course
are going to and from the courthouse
every day during this trial past the
national guardsmen the barbed wire they
know that stuff exists for a reason they
were told by the judge look we'll try to
keep your identity secret while you're
in court which is nonsense because all
these people disappeared from their
normal jobs for three weeks at a time
right so everyone in their circle social
circle knows that they're not gone
they're not there for a reason
and they know eventually the judge told
them we will release your names to the
public yeah and
it's not going to be a good outcome from
i mean the the defense uh use of force
expert had blood and a pig's head left
at his former home
that wasn't intended to intimidate him
or change his testimony his testimony
was over right it was for the jurors
right it was for the benefit and by the
way this applies also to every
prospective juror witness expert for any
of these future trials coming up the
written house trial coming up the
mccloskey trial coming up the ahmad
arbury trial coming up all those people
also everyone going through jury
selection there knows what to anticipate
now
let me uh pull up a story real quick
because there's something that you're
you're getting me uh
here we go it's bbc
ladies and gentlemen
we have this story from the bbc
anger as ex-generals warn of deadly
civil war in france now the reasons
they're giving for why they think france
will descend into civil wars is a bit
different they're talking about you know
what they call no-go zones in french
neighborhoods but in an open letter to
the president they mentioned this
leftist dogma is going to result in
their country descending into civil war
now we're not france i understand that
but seeing this story
and then hearing what you just said
we're talking about the chauvin trial
the the pig's head and blood left at
someone's home the riots and the threats
from maxine waters we have federal
politicians saying unless we get
mob justice
we will riot more right how can there be
confidence in this government in our
country similar to what i'm you know
it's not one for one with what the
french generals were saying
but with this leftist dogma it seems
like their their moral framework is
there is no truth but power and might
makes right that's what they believe
why would any
um you know individual in this country
who believes in the america american
moral framework innocent until proven
guilty just sit by and let this happen
now i understand for the time being they
are they are after everything we saw in
minnesota there are still people who
would believe or ignore
you know what's happening
they would believe the lies or ignore
what's happening in this state but for
those of us that are paying attention
it's getting it's getting terrifying
because this is look
there's an argument in my opinion based
on everything i've read maybe
manslaughter i don't know what's your
opinion on the show maybe manslaughter i
think there was reasonable doubt on
every one of them charges yeah that
doesn't mean he didn't do something
wrong uh it doesn't even mean you know
it could be probably true that he
committed a crime but that's not the
legal standard the legal standard is it
has to be proven beyond a reasonable
doubt and i did not see that here i i i
agree um i guess what i'm trying to say
is if someone told me that based on
everything that was presented to the
jurors the jurors found you know maybe
manslaughter i'd be like that makes
sense i guess i wouldn't you know i
might not agree with that but it's
guilty on all accounts second-degree
murder i
watched hours of deliberations
this is a case in which there were over
55 exhib 55 000 exhibits of evidence
in which there was sufficient video that
individual expert witnesses said they
spent 100 to 150 hours reviewing the
video evidence and the jurors
went into deliberations in less than 10
hours later came back with a verdict
that that wasn't due deliberation and
argument over the evidence in that case
and whether it met the legal standard
that was people who were terrorized and
i think the public looks at this look
first of all you have to
you'd have to accept that a jury that
effectively has a gun to its head is
anything like any model of justice any
of us would want for ourselves or a
loved one because that's effectively
what happened in this case but first
people would have to recognize that
that's what happened and second of all
even if they did recognize that this was
a gross injustice and by the way it's a
gross injustice regardless of the
verdict so chauvin could have been
convicted in a fair process and justice
in america is not supposed to be about
the outcome it's supposed to be about a
just process if we trust the process we
accept the outcome regardless of what it
might be but if the process is
inherently corrupt you don't get
anything like justice out the other end
so first you have to recognize that the
process is corrupt but even if you do
recognize that well what's an individual
person supposed to do about it except
hope that when they're swimming in the
water the shark doesn't happen to come
for them thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you